ich habe doch gesagt nicht anklicken
damit widerlegen freunde herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einer neuen
serie auf einem kanal denn von nun an
gibt es jeden
und ich bin ganz ehrlich freunde ich
habe twitch für mich entdeckt als ich
kann das wird schon länger als halt
diese plattform wo man sich live streams
anschauen kann allerdings habe ich mir
wirklich noch nie über ein längeren
zeitraum sonderleistung halt angeschaut
ist vor zwei wochen war ich mir
natürlich einen stream angeguckt montana
black als ich so zehn oder elf war habe
ich mir so ein kleines lego schwert von
so einer figur in meiner eure gesteckt
weil ich nicht wusste was ich da mal
[Musik]
dann hat montana blick auf jeden fall
eine spende vorgelesen bekommen hat im 2
ich würde ich gern kennenlernen ohne
welche absicht wirklich vorlesen dann
hat man in seinem leipziger meine person
gebannt und es hörte sich irgendwie so
an als wäre er seinen lehrer und hätte
gerade ein schüler rausgeschickt ich
glaube für dich aber du bist nicht mehr
lange teilzunehmen wenn der zuschauer
dann das nächste mal wiederkommen wird
es wahrscheinlich so aussehen und was
mir auch aufgefallen ist ist das montana
black wirklich gute manieren sehr am
herzen liegen
vor einigen tagen hat meinte dann auch
ein pokemon karten auf in den gemacht
und im gegensatz zu läuten das wirklich
professionell machen und dann mit
behutsamkeit rangehen an die packs mit
einer schere auf gemacht da musste ich
wirklich kompletten los und haben
manches stück kaum verlassen und bin zu
sascha gegangen der anscheinend auch
twitch livestreams macht
stabile face cam bruder schmeckt müller
milch mit wodka jetta tessin war jan
probiert müller milch mit wodka
muttermilch schokolade mit 43
[Applaus]
muttermilch schokolade mit likör 43
menschen
doch sascha war tatsächlich auch in dem
pokémon partner opening von monte mit
dabei und hat sich ein tour tag
gewünscht und das auch bekommen echt
krass sascha hat sich dann auch
besonders krass gefreut
keine ahnung was die lüfte getan hat
sascha allerdings hat er danach ein
ballerspiel gespielt indem seine team
mates allerdings nicht so gespielt haben
ja das wollte ich lotto spielen
[Musik]
dann hab ich allerdings gedacht mensch
wenn man an sascha denkt und an
stuttgart denkt denkt man auch an ins
coop an nico und dann bin ich auf seinen
twitter-account gegangen
[Musik]
ich bin von migros account direkt wieder
weggegangen und rüber zu papa platte
weil sie den ich kennen solltet ihr in
ganz kurzer ausschnitt kann auf jeden
fall will ich bin meistens aber der typ
keine weiteren fragen sich jetzt fragen
sollte was papa platte sonst und seinen
streams macht er spielt leidenschaftlich
gern beispielsweise mario kart wii
version von einem roten getroffen queens
wenn kevin allerdings kein mario kart
spielt beantwortet er auch manchmal
fragen zum thema beziehung und frauen
dann spreche ich bin glaube ich nie
vorstellen so girl auf der straße einem
run zu werben und so zu sagen hey du
siehst gut aus kann ich ja noch mal ich
habe es ein oder zwei mal gemacht also
ich könnte mir echt überhaupt nicht
vorstellen dass tomate ich hab's ein
oder zwei mal gemacht
wenn papa platte allerdings gerade keine
windstöße sieht mario kart spielt oder
wertvolle frauen anmacht tipps verteilt
dann benutzt er sehr häufig englische
wörter in seinen streams und einmal hat
er eine challenge bekommen für den
nächsten zwei minuten keine englischen
wörter sagt okay aber gut sagen wir okay
ist kein englisches wort ich meine okay
ist kein englisches wort oder sagen wir
buch ist ein ausdruck der boom ist
einfach nur gut dass konnten sich meine
gehirnzellen nicht mehr lange geben von
da habe ich mir gedacht ich dir über zu
einem anderen tisch livestream ab wo man
das auf jeden fall ein bisschen auf dem
nächstes level heben kann was die
intelligenzquotienten angeht 3 max heißt
er nämlich handschlag
[Musik]
es würden immer schneller
das wird immer schneller das willkommen
wenn er was wird immer schnell hat sie
doch ist auch sie traurig das alter
[Musik]
welcher jahrgang bist du 97 94 du ja ich
hab dann auf jeden fall mir ein paar
andere alte live streams von den drei
werke angeschaut habe dann gesehen dass
er manchmal auch zockt beispiel naja ich
hab das schon mal gemacht ist ging in
der situation darum dass er irgendwie
sondern selbst gebauten helikopter
steuern musste und remakes meint er dass
er das schon mal gemacht hat von da habe
ich mich ein bisschen informiert wie
sein erster flug mit diesem helikopter
ablief gegeben dass er wie fit man denn
aber gut was nicht wird das kann ja noch
werden von daher habe ich ihm die daumen
gedrückt und was geworden ist mit seinem
flug ihr ja ja ja ja ja dass das war
jetzt also klappt ja ich hab es dann
eigentlich schon den kompletten glauben
in deutschland verloren bis ich dann
noch auf sie hier gestoßen ist euer
finger heiß
das einzige was jetzt noch fehlt ist das
sägen typ sagt dass eine halbe stunde
fast 30 minuten sind wurde halbe stunde
sind fast 60 minuten beim abschluss es
muss doch eine einzige person geben die
live-streams macht die hände sind wir
sind was vermitteln kann die irgendwie
einen vielleicht lieben hans tipps geben
kann oder so dann bin ich auf seinen
account gestoßen jeremy fragrance und
jeremy fragrance gibt uns hier jetzt
finanztipps auch wenn wir zu 1000 euro
im monat zur verfügung haben ich meinen
1000 euro pro monat kriegt jeder von uns
zusammen von mir ausgehen davor 650 euro
für miete weg dann wer zehn euro pro tag
für essen
das wären dann 300 euro dann musst du
eben
also wenn du nur 1000 euro im monat
machst dann würde ich dir empfehlen mehr
zu machen das heutige wir jetzt auch
beenden meine lieben freunde wenn euch
heute die ärzte so das will gefeiert
anlass gerne einen daumen hoch unter dem
video hier da schreibt ihr und in die
kommentare welche - auf jeden fall denn
das nächste video rein müssen abonniert
main kanal falls doch keine lokalseite
und wir sehen uns morgen wieder wenn sie
da ist
[Musik]